hey everyone
welcome to this session today's topic
is react versus angular so what's in it
for you
we'll first get familiar with both the
programming languages
by going through a quick introduction
then we will compare react and angular
focusing on their performance
after that we will discuss the learning
curve for learning both of these
frameworks
we'll also get to know about the
adoption of these frameworks
and their application in the field of
web development
after that we'll compare the community
support available for each framework
then we will dive into the industry
trends and job prospects
and in the end i'm going to tell you
which technology to choose
but i will give you enough food for
thought for you to choose the technology
that suits you
and your project best so let me first
give you an introduction
to react now react is javascript library
for ui development
it is managed by facebook and has an
open source community of developers
the framework was introduced in may 2013
it is currently one of the most popular
front-end libraries
for web development moving on to angular
angular is an open source javascript
framework
for web development and mobile
development it is typescript based and
is managed by google's angular team
and the angular developer community
launched in september 2016
angular also known as angular 2.0 is a
complete rewrite of angularjs
which was introduced in 2010 it competes
directly with react front-end library
moving on let's go ahead and compare the
performance
now react's performance is greatly
improved with the introduction of the
virtual dom
and is generally better than that of
angular
the act uses the concept of virtual dom
that puts less load on the browser
react was released with the usb of being
faster than other frameworks available
furthermore since the data binding
process is unidirectional
bindings are not assigned watchers as in
the case of angular
when it comes to angular it performs
worse especially in complex and dynamic
applications the performance of angular
apps is negatively affected
by bi-directional data binding angular
uses traditional dom that updates the
whole web page
even if a single element is changed
however
the most recent update of angular has
greatly improved its performance
and it does not lose to react anymore
so moving ahead let me give you a brief
insight into the learning curve
react is a library and not a framework
it is quite simple to understand
if you're familiar with javascript
however it takes time to learn how to
set up a project properly
so you need to learn the redux library
which is used in more than half of
react applications for state management
react depends on other libraries to add
functionality
constant framework updates also require
additional effort from the developer
when it comes to angular it is a
full-fledged mvc framework
although typescript closely resembles
javascript it also takes some time to
learn
now angular is more complex to
understand some complicated features are
embedded into the framework
core which means that the developer
cannot avoid learning and using them
angular itself is a huge library so
initial learning effort is worth it
since you probably won't have to learn
other libraries like react moving ahead
let's look at the community support
react framework is one of the most
popular javascript frameworks
worldwide it has larger community
support
and you may face a lack of documentation
at times the community support makes up
for the lack and documentation
when it comes to angular even though
angular was released before
its adoption is lesser when compared to
react
comparatively it has a smaller community
support
documentation is on point and definitely
better in the case of angular
also the community support has improved
over the few years
moving on let's look at adoption and
application
react was released in may 2013. react is
more popularly adopted by developers due
to its simplicity
it is actively used by companies like
facebook twitter
netflix airbnb and many others now here
new york times is one of the many
popular websites built using react
every new section acts as a separate
component so if
any one of the component updates the
entire web page doesn't have to reload
making the web app feel much faster and
smoother
this is just to give you a brief example
when it comes to angular it was released
in october 2010.
even though it is improved now
developers used to ignore angular due to
its complexity at the time of its
release
angular is used by google apple nike
mcdonald's and other companies
now gmail is one of the many popular
websites built using angular
only the initial loading takes time but
after that
everything is so smooth because it is
pre-loaded onto the web browser
so moving on let's look at the industry
trends
first up is the market trends now let's
have a look at the google trends chart
that shows the search popularity of
react and angular in the last five years
we can clearly make out that react's
popularity is increasing over time
while angular's popularity is more of a
straight line
moving on to job trends a react
developer's average salary in the united
states is around 91 000 us dollars per
annum
in india the average salary of a
reactive lopper is around 7.35 lakhs per
annum
when it comes to angular an average
salary of an angular developer
in the us is around 73 000 us dollars
when it comes to india the average
salary is around 4.88 lakhs per annum
so in conclusion angular is a
full-fledged mobile and web development
framework
react is a library only for ui
development which can be turned into a
full-fledged solution with the help of
additional libraries
react seems simpler at first sight and
it takes lesser time to start working on
a react project
however that simplicity as the main
advantage of react is neutralized
because you have to learn to work
with additional frameworks and tools
angular itself is more complex and takes
quite some time to master
yet it is a powerful tool that offers a
holistic web development experience
and once you learn how to work with it
you reap the fruits
now there is no better framework both
are updated
continuously to keep up with the
competitor for instance
while react was believed to win because
of its virtual dom
angular equaled the score by
implementing change detection
in the end angular vs react is all a
matter of personal preference
a matter of skills and habits as a
beginner in programming
you would probably benefit more from
starting with angular
as an experienced developer you just
keep working with what you know better
so with that i'd like to end this
session i hope you liked it
do you think we missed out on anything
important let us know in the chat
section below
thank you so much for watching and thank
you so much for tuning in we're going to
be back with more videos soon
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here